alors que le secteur de la culture est
toujours à l'arrêt la salle du temps
machine organisent la riposte avec des
concerts à domicile
le concept est tout simple vous réservez
votre groupe et les artistes
investissent votre salon pour 10 euros
seulement
la jauge est limitée à 6 personnes petit
aperçu avec l artiste créneau qu'a qui
jouait dans un salon familial du
quartier rabelais à tours
aurélie renault avec son ampli ces
câbles et son micro nastasia alias
créneau qu'a s'installe au milieu d'un
salon dans lequel elle n'a jamais mis
les pieds
nous sommes chez ségolène les rich et
leurs deux filles pour un concert privé
[Musique]
ça fait vraiment quelque temps qu'on n'a
pas vu de spectacle vivant et du coup
bah vous devez qu'initiative vraiment
super chouette et on a des amis qui
l'ont fait il ya deux semaines qui avait
trouvé ça bien donc ça nous a donné
envie de passer le pas d'ordinaire
créneau qu'a fait partie du groupe et
vanille cette fois elle est seule non
pas en scène mais à domicile et la magie
opère immédiatement
[Musique]
vingt minute d'un subtil mélange de
douceur et de pop créneau qu'a et son
sampler illumine le salon familial le
sans fil et je le ressens pas mais
peut-être parce que j'ai déjà fait ça
plein de fois avec teva ni du coup quand
on est en concert acoustique
il n'y a pas de scène forcément y'a pas
forcément lumière on est juste là avec
les gens et je pense peut-être
l'expérience fait que je me sens pas en
danger en tout cas on est bien dans ce
salon web mais très bien mais c'est la
salle du temps machine qui orchestre les
concerts à domicile
la jauge est limitée à 6 personnes et le
prix est symbolique 10 euros pour une
expérience inédite la méridienne koffi
n'a pas dit non sans blague
krajisnik voit dans ses choix de mal
dont elles ont elles ont bien aimé on
les a vus on les a vus ce dandiner en
rythme donc je pense qu'ils ont beaucoup
aimé
c'était très bien un concert mais
également une rencontre un échange et
même un test avec le sampler une
parenthèse hors des salles mais un
spectacle bien réel